yeah Mr Speaker I'm sure that colleagues
from across the house will join me in
congratulating Liverpool for its
wonderful staging of the Eurovision song
contest on behalf of Ukraine
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
and in addition to my duties in this
house I shall have further such meetings
later today
[Music]
Royal Lancaster infirmary is a 130 year
old crumbling hospital and was meant to
be one of the government's 40 new
hospitals however the funding
announcement has been delayed four times
already so can the Deputy Prime Minister
reassure my constituents that this is
not going to be another broken Tory
promise
[Applause]
I can absolutely assure The Honorable
lady that we remain fully committed to
those 40 hospitals from our Manifesto
and indeed
already provided 3.9 billion pounds
worth of initial Capital
Craig McKinley Mr Speaker I have a very
serious matter affecting every
constituency to bring to my right
honorable friends attention
Amazon have been facilitating the sale
of counterfeit postage stamps from China
virtually perfect except for the barcode
I've contacted the NCA the national
trading standards and I'm afraid I've
received woeful responses I've now set
my concerns to the series Fraud Office
and the economic crime unit of the city
of London Police
facilitating remittances of illegal
gotten cash and I believe this is in
contravention of the forgery and
counterfeiting act 1981 can my right
honorable friend assist me in taking
this further
well Mr Speaker may I pay tribute to my
honorable friend I know how hard he has
been campaigning on this important issue
the Home Secretary will have heard his
remarks I would say that the digital
markets and competition and consumer
bill does put duties on those platforms
and ultimately if fraud is being
perpetrated the police should take
action we don't come to the deputy
leader of the opposition Angela radar
thank you Mr Speaker and it's a pleasure
to welcome you another deputy prime
minister for the dispatch box the third
Deputy that I faced in three years and
you know what they say the third time's
a charm and I'm also pleased to note Mr
Speaker that the Prime Minister as a
working-class friend finally
I seem to remember that after the loss
of 300 conservative seats at last year's
local elections the right honorable
gentleman resigned saying someone must
take responsibility after a thousand
more conservative councilors have been
given the boot by vultures who does he
think is responsible now
[Applause]
speaker in in the the spirit of the
writing ladies opening remarks can I
just say it really is a pleasure to see
the right honorable lady here today I
was though expecting to face the labor
leaders choice for the next Deputy Prime
Minister if they win the election so I'm
surprised that the lib Dem leader isn't
taking questions
[Applause]
and Mr Speaker
you will forgive me
Mr Speaker you you will forgive me if I
take the right honorable ladies
predictions with a pinch of salt after
all she confidently predicted that the
right honorable member for Islington
North would one day be prime minister
remember this is a man who wanted to
abolish the army scrap Trident
withdrawal from NATO and abandon Ukraine
and what did she say to that she
couldn't wait for him to be prime
minister
Mr Speaker it's absolutely amazing that
while the labor party is preparing to
govern with a labor majority
[Music]
Mr Speaker and this week at the national
conservative conference a member for
devisers blame the country's problems on
a new religion he even hit out at the
dystopian fantasy of John Lennon the
member for pentastone and Stockbridge
said identifying for all in birthing
rates is the overarching threat to the
UK she criticized well teaching and for
destroying children's souls and calls in
self-harm and suicide among people and
the right honorable member for Northeast
Somerset really let the cat out the bag
when he said parties that tried to
gerrymander end up finding their clever
schemes come back to bite them as dare I
said we found when investing insisting
on Volta ID the very honorable gentleman
opposite while working in number 10 said
he had to listen to the radio every
morning to find out what was really
going on in the country apparently he
was surprised on a daily basis by what
he learned and most the best time were
spent on day-to-day crisis Management in
lives on Mr Speaker
[Music]
I'm not quite sure what the question was
there Mr Speaker
she wants to talk about this all this
sort of
Sol and her leader it's all lovey-dovey
on the surface they turn it on for the
cameras but as soon as they're off it's
a different story they're at each
other's throats Mr Speaker they're the
Phil and Holly of British politics
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
Deputy leader of the opposition thank
you Mr Speaker the reality is after 13
years of toryville they're still
lurching from crisis to crisis and
wallowing in their own mess they can't
solve the crisis because they are the
crisis The Honorable member opposite
shall take more note of what's happening
at his conferences in his party before
trying to make up what's happening in
mind
Minister pledged that by March NHS
waiting list would fall it's now May so
can he tell us since he made that pledge
is the number of people waiting on late
waiting lists higher or lower
Mr Speaker we are making a good progress
for example with two-year waiting lists
but the right honorable lady seems to
forget a crucial fact the United Kingdom
experienced an unprecedented pandemic
right before covid GP satisfaction was
high delayed discharges were half
ambulance targets were being met and she
knows that right now in labor-run Wales
exactly the same challenges are being
faced the difference between this is on
this side of the house we've got a plan
to fix it while she's too busy playing
pessy politics
[Applause]
cut even before the pandemic waiting
lists were going up so it doesn't wash
that this Government after 13 years in
power is blaming everybody
but themselves
people are having to put up with he
appears to be claiming that 11 000
patients waiting more than 18 months is
an achievement the last Labor government
reduce waiting times from 18 months to
18 weeks and he can come back to me when
he's achieved that the fact is Mr
Speaker waiting list longer than when
the Prime Minister made his pledge five
months ago
months ago number of people in England
waiting to start hospital treatment is
the highest since records began
7.3 million patients left waiting now I
know the Prime Minister has his own
private GP so maybe he doesn't
appreciate the urgency but he's left
people like my constituent Carol waiting
for over a year for an urgent
appointment move from waiting list to
waiting list of appointments canceled
again and again so if not now when we're
waiting list
it'll continue to lay at the end of this
question the more if I get any more
interruptions it will take longer Miss
Mr Speaker they don't want to hear the
question because they know the answer
[Applause]
to people so
so far
Deputy Prime Minister
well I would gently say to the right
honorable lady if he cares that much
about access to our health care why is
she opposing our minimum service levels
they will provide poor emergency
services with vital coverage during
Healthcare strikes does she not think
that vulnerable patients deserve that
level of care or is she too weak to
stand up to her union pay masters
Mr Speaker we are we all want minimum
service levels it says government
[Applause]
Bibles and in all of our trains and all
of our Public Services because they've
run them down and mismanaged them for
the last 13 years now it's not just
waiting times Mr Speaker 13 years after
the landlord Marmot review into child
poverty so Michael says this government
is on track to make child poverty worse
with more than a quarter of our children
living in poverty last year when I was a
young mum I remember the sick feeling in
my stomach not knowing if my wages would
cover the bills yet his government has
taken a wrecking ball to measures by the
last Labor government to eradicate child
poverty even abolishing the child
poverty unit they tried to justify this
by saying they no longer needed a child
poverty unit because they've abolished
the child poverty targets so can you
tell us what level of poverty he
considered to be a success
foreign
lady this comprehensive school boy is
not going to take any lectures from the
party opposite
out the lives of working people what I
would say is that we have introduced
record increases in the National living
wage something that this party
introduced the party opposite failed to
do so and we have taken one million
working age people out of poverty
altogether that is the record of my
party and one of which I am very proud
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker the last Labor government
made it their mission to reduce the
number of children in poverty by a
million we achieved that under the
Tories child poverty is nearly back to
the level it was when labor last
inhibited the Tory mess after 13 years
of the Tories they're stuck in a
conveyor belt of Crisis and while his
party is preparing for opposition with
their Trump tribute act conference over
the road
labor are focused on fixing the real
problems facing British people the
Tories have picked their side they're
for the vested interest for the oil
companies and the bankers for those that
are profiting from the crisis and not
suffering from it whether it's failing
the millions of people anxiously waiting
for treatment or overseeing a rise in
child poverty and while these colleagues
felt nonsense at their Carnival of
conspiracy I want to know when will his
party stop blaming everybody else and
realize that the problem is them
[Applause]
proudly defend our record in office
Prime down 50
near record levels of employment a a
record minimum wage and what Mr Speaker
what's their record for general election
defeats
he promises already broken and one
leader who let anti-Semitism run wild
that that is why the British people will
never trust the labor party
[Music]
thank you very much Mr Speaker would my
right honorable friend please send his
condolences to the family of Hilton Ward
councilor Jillian lemon who at the young
age of 52 tragically died partway
through the election counts on Friday
this means that the whole election for
all three councilors has had to be
voided even though the returning officer
was ready to declare three conservative
councilors for the Hilton Ward perhaps
following this Dreadful experience my
right honorable friend will confirm that
the best way to thank councilor Julian
lemon for her service is for the good
people of Hilton ward in South
Derbyshire to vote again three times for
the three conservative candidates on
Thursday the 15th of June
thank you
well Mr Speaker may may I extend uh my
deepest sympathies on behalf of these
benches and the conservative party to
councilor Jillian lemon's family we all
know how incredibly hard local
councilors work and she was a strong
representative of South Derbyshire and
like my honorable friend I do hope that
the people of Hilton Ward will reflect
on this by voting for conservative
candidates at the forthcoming election
[Music]
very black
thank you Mr Speaker in 2016 the Deputy
Prime Minister told his constituents in
a blog that it was his duty to and I
quote furnish them with all the facts
that are available with regards to
brexit today brexit Britain faces higher
food prices a lack of workers a
shrinking economy and a decline in
living standards why is he happy to
ignore those facts yeah the Prime
Minister well Mr Speaker we have one of
the fastest growth rates in the whole of
the G7 since we all we all know and In
fairness we all know the policy of the
SNP and they said it this weekend I
quote we need to undo brexit but let me
tell you
if I were them I'd start by undoing the
mess they've left Scotland in and start
working with
focus on the priorities of this
the simple not the priorities of their
party are they black check the deal must
that speaker the the only thing more
deluded than that defensive brexit is
the labor party support of it
just today the world's fourth largest
car manufacturer said that brexit was
and again I quote a threat to our export
business and the sustainability of our
UK manufacturing options even Nigel
farage can admit that brexit has failed
so Mr Speaker why can't he yeah
Mr
right I would say to The Honorable lady
one of the best ways of getting behind
industry in this country is get behind
the trade deals we're striving with many
countries around the world which they
have singularly failed to oppose and and
I see last week the SMP promised to
build a New Scotland I don't know
whether she's aware but the s p have
been in power for 13 years
stop their focus on Independence and
focus on the priorities of the Scottish
people
estimate me
thank you Mr Speaker
my constituency has a problem with
Travelers
Travelers pitching on private land and
common land and causing a nuisance
currently on Park gate industrial estate
in Knutsford either the police don't
have sufficient powers to deal with this
issue or they do have sufficient Powers
but they're not using them so will the
Deputy Prime Minister get the government
to speak with Cheshire police to ensure
that they do have the powers to deal
with this plight on our local community
and that they use them
the right honorable lady my original
friend is absolutely right to highlight
the misery caused by unauthorized
encampments I've seen this in my own
constituency as well I understand that
home office officials do regular liaise
with the National Police Chiefs Council
on this but of course my right on my
friend the Home Secretary will have
heard my writer and Friends
representations and I trust you a lot on
those so Jeffrey Donald
speaker the Deputy Prime Minister will
be aware of the ongoing concerns of
unionists in Northern Ireland about our
ability to trade freely within the
United Kingdom and its internal Market
given the continued application of EU
law on the manufacture of all Goods in
Northern Ireland we now have proposals
for a future border operating model that
could potentially create further
barriers to trade between Northern and
Great Britain will the Deputy Prime
Minister give me an assurance that the
government will in law protect Northern
Ireland's ability to trade freely within
and with the rest of the United Kingdom
yes well I I would like to say that we
have already shown a willingness to
legislate to protect Northern Ireland's
place within the union and we're
committed to providing exactly the
protections at the right honor of
gentleman refers to around Northern
Ireland's unfettered access to the whole
United Kingdom market so I can give
those assurances and of course we stand
ready to work with the right honorable
gentleman and representatives across
unionism to reflect the further steps
required to strengthen our precious
union Richardson thank you Mr Speaker
throughout the early hours of Saturday
morning I was out with Kathy Peter Joe
and Tim who volunteer as Guildford
Street angels I paid tribute to them and
all the volunteers who are out every
weekend and in all weather but Mr
Speaker it's an absolute disgrace that
the liberal Democrat run Council shut
the public lose
at night at night there are no single
sex spaces for our young woman and they
are seeking out dark secluded areas of
their Court short which is dangerous
their increased risk of sexual assault
will my right honorable friend join me
in calling for the immediate reopening
of the Town Center lose in Guilford
well I I thank my honorable friend for
raising this a very important issue and
and sadly I'm afraid that's what one
might expect from a live Dem run Council
uh I do join her in thanking the
Guildford Street angels for all of their
efforts and I'm sure that they and she
will continue to make those views known
to Guilford Borough Council
yeah thank you very much Mr Speaker many
of my constituents are struggling to pay
the bills and put food on their table
food prices have risen by over 19 in the
last year the cheapest infant formula up
45 gas prices up 129 electricity up 67
many report borrowing more money than
this time last year with car
manufacturers to intimate production
they'll be asking 100 billion has been
lost from the economy forever and wages
falling further and further behind a
basic living expenses so it does he
really still believe his government's
Kamikaze brexit is delivering for the
people of these hours
Deputy Prime Minister I certainly I do
believe that Mr Speaker and I would I
would say to the to to to the members on
those benches that it's only because of
the strength of our United Kingdom that
we're able to afford the sort of
interventions for example that we've had
with the cost of living with over 3 300
pounds for every single family in our
United Kingdom paid for by a 75 windfall
tax on oil and gas companies that's a
United Kingdom delivering on the cost of
living
thank you Mr Speaker in 2016 we secured
over 300 million pounds for the
modernization of a D services in
Shropshire
is on that money has still not been
spent and construction hasn't started I
have a real concern about the quality of
managers within our local NHS trust that
this decision has not been taken what
can my right honorable friend do to help
us interrupture to ensure that finally
the 312 million pounds is spent and at a
D services are modernized because there
is nothing more important than the
safety of constituents when they go into
a D services Deputy Prime Minister
oh well I I pay tribute to my honorable
for raising this issue I know that his
constituents are anxious for building
work to get underway as soon as possible
and I know that the department for
health are working closely with NHS
England and the trust to support the
development of the scheme and the trust
is due to submit plans to the Department
of Health in the coming months and the
department will work at PACE to review
those plans Marshall Dakota
thank you Mr Speaker leaseholders in
Battersea are trapped in an outdated and
unfair leasehold system the Secretary of
State said and I quote the government
would absolutely maintain a commitment
to abolish the leasehold system and
would bring forward legislation shortly
but we now know that this is no longer
the case so Deputy Prime Minister why
has the government yet again done
another U-turn and yet again broken and
never promised to Lee soldiers to scrap
its plans to end the outdated lease yeah
well I'd like to reassure the honor
related members of this house that the
government is committed to reforming the
leaseholder system to give homeowners
greater control and give cheaper uh
access to leaseholder Renewal including
a 990-year extension with zero Financial
ground rent and we will set out plans
for further reforms later in this
Parliament so Desmond sway what would be
a reason for extending the general
election franchise to settle the EU
citizens a population of Voters equal to
the number in Wales
well I I think the my uh honorable
friends is referring to the plans from
the party opposite and it's actually
quite interesting that that this week
well we're pushing ahead with
legislation to break the smuggling gangs
what's Labor's big idea give foreign
Nationals a say in our elections so
there we have it
well the conservatives will stop the
boats labor will rig the
rig the
thank you Mr Speaker I was concerned to
read last week that the Prime Minister
had to be airlifted to a pharmacy in
Southampton after suffering electoral
dysfunction
several weeks earlier he flew all the
way from Lancashire to Yorkshire by
private jet
meanwhile angry real commuters faced a
reality of cancellations longer Journey
times and are unable to get to work on
time as operators shed Services the
public think that the prime ministers
got his head in the clouds they're right
aren't they
[Applause]
[Music]
it is quite extraordinary speaker to
take lectures from the party opposite
about the railways when actually the
head of the train drivers Union actually
sits on Labor's NEC
leader of the labor party as quote one
of us no wonder labor won't stand up to
the militant rail unions they literally
let them Drive their policies
[Applause]
Mr Speaker incredible regeneration work
is taking place on T side led by our
mayor Ben houch
[Applause]
we have seen a shameful attempt to smear
the amazing tease Works project led by
The Honorable member for Middlesbrough
who I've given advanced notice to yeah
will he confirm that it was always an
integral part of the business case that
the private sector should co-invest
alongside government and that the t's
Works Arrangements themselves have been
checked and approved by the government
and will he reconfirm his full support
for the tease Works project reassure
investors and join me in calling for the
labor party to apologize for talking
downtown
well my right honor a friend is
absolutely correct to raise this issue
it is the UK's first Freeport and it
continues to attract billions of pounds
of private sector investment creating
jobs and supporting the local economy
and I think the whole house will see
through the inexcusable attempts by the
labor party to talk down those successes
on T side where local leaders are
working tirelessly to improve that
region for the first time in a
generation
thank you Mr Speaker in 2011 the first
year that the Tories came into
government 61 61
000 people received emergency food
Parcels from food banks in 2022-23 that
figure had gone up to nearly 3 million
one million of them children
it's gone up every year that the
conservatives have been in power bar one
so will you tell the house is that a
record that he proudly defends
I'm very proud of the fact that this
government has given record numbers of
people the opportunities had jobs and
employment which is the surest route out
of poverty and it is the case that I
believe up to 3.6 million new jobs have
been created under this government
Walker
it's truly excellent news See England
rising up the international league
tables for reading to become the highest
performing country in the West the
Western world that's Testament for hard
work of our teachers and
to follow evidence-based policy but this
progress will only be sustained if
children are in school regularly able to
learn so can I strongly commend him into
the government the 10-minute rule Bill
presented by my honorable friend for me
on Valley has cross-party support
delivers on key recommendations of the
education celebrity and the children's
commissioner for government should adopt
it as soon as possible
okay
well my my honorable friend is
absolutely right to highlight those
brilliant figures which show that we've
now jumped to the fourth best in the
whole world for reading and I certainly
see in in schools it's much much more
demanding than it was in my day and
that's tribute to the ministerial team
that have done such a a fabulous job I
would of course examine the details of
the 10-minute rule Bill to which he
refers Tommy Shepherd
Mr Speaker it is an Open Secret that
many in the conservative party would
wish to roll back the Democratic gains
of devolution either in part or
completely the noble Lord Frost former
Minister the architect of the disastrous
brexit agreement and now I believe
seeking a safe tourist seat in this
chamber recently let the cat out of the
bag when he said the government should
review and roll back some devolved
Powers just try it does the Deputy Prime
Minister agree with him yeah yeah
I would say to the olden gentleman the
only thing that will destroy Devolution
is a vote for Independence in Scotland
as advocated by those on those
[Music]
on those
thank you very much Mr Speaker and can I
congratulate my right one friend on a
brilliant first performance at Primus
but he keep the government laser focused
on the issues that matter to people like
the cost of living in the NHS and on the
issues of the future like artificial
intelligence which needs regulatory
attention and ignore the reactionary
voices no matter where they come from
[Music]
well my my writer and friend is is
absolutely right to to highlight this
I'm incredibly optimistic about the
future of this country in Industries
across the piece including digital or
indeed film and television in my own
constituency we're genuinely World
leading creating high quality jobs that
we want our children or grandchildren to
have show more thank you Mr Speaker half
the children in Newcastle Central are
growing up in poverty shopping over the
last five years the delivery of food
Parcels to Northeast children has risen
by 250 percent the number of Northeast
children who are homeless Rose by 50
last year on average their parents wages
will have fallen by a thousand pounds
and if any of this affects their mental
health they face a five-month wait for
treatment why is his government making
it so hard for our kids yeah
this house needs a correction on the
facts given what's what's come from the
party opposite it is the case that
because of our national living wage uh
defined as more than at least two-thirds
of median income that said its lowest
point for years and we've actually
lifted 1.7 million people out of
absolute poverty all together that is
the track record of this government
good let's thank you very much Mr
Speaker the people of Longport and
burslem as well as Port Hill and my
neighboring constituency neighbor of
Newcastle to Lima suffering because of
cowboy waste disposals like
Staffordshire waste who have now been
again done for having wasted was not
meant to be on site and have been given
a notice by the environment agency what
support can I get in holding these
people to account and making sure that
their retrospective planning application
for a site that they're using which they
didn't get planning permission on before
using is rejected by Stoke-on-Trent City
Council
well my my honorable friend is right to
raise this uh this issue of of those
kind of people and indeed we often see
them associated with fly tipping which
is a blight on our landscape I will
ensure that I raise all the issues that
he has raised with me with my right
honorable friends at the Secretary of
State for leveling up who has
ministerial responsibility for this
Rachel vascal thank you Mr Speaker
crisis Mental Health Services are in
crisis patients and families gaslit and
at risk it is mental health awareness
week but no government awareness to
ensure my constituents are safe your
funding and Workforce needs met so why
is his government sat on their hands
with a devastating report sat on the
health secretary's desk well my pain
while patients in York and across the
NHS are being failed can I and the trust
have an urgent meeting yeah
well I'm sure one of my ministerial
colleagues in the health team will be
happy to have that meeting I would just
say that under this government we put
more money into Mental Health Services
and actually we're funding 150 wider
Capital schemes so this government has
made Mental Health Services a priority
final question Virginia Crosby thank you
Mr Speaker this week is Wales tourism
week an opportunity to celebrate one of
wales's most important businesses which
represents 10 of all jobs supports Welsh
farmers and food producers and generates
six billion pounds in economic activity
each year with the Deputy Prime Minister
join me in thanking all those that work
in the Wales tourism sector and would he
agree with me that this UK government's
tips Bill demonstrates its commitment to
supporting the tourism sector unlike
laboring Cardiff whose proposed tourism
tax will undermine visits and undermine
jobs
well of course I'm most happy to give
that commitment to my honorable friend
indeed I have spent many happy family
holidays in Wales and plan to do so
again next year
I'm complete prime minister's questions
so there we have it Oliver Dan's first
pmq is deputizing of course roshi sunak
um the prime minister in Japan for the
G7 Summit up against Angela and our
Deputy political editor Samurai Sam
Coates is here
I can't sing that well
um I can't I can't decide which which
was my favorite jab whether it was Raina
saying it's a pleasure to welcome you
yet another deputy prime minister to the
dispatch box the third Deputy I faced in
three years third time's a charm or if
it was Dad and saying kissed armor and
Angela Rainer are the villain Holly of
British politics oh give me give me Phil
and Holly any day of the week my God
that was painful I mean lame gags kind
of weak jibes over long questions
somebody edit the edit those questions
down because it was one of those
premises questions you know with the
deputies where the deputies didn't do
the deputy title that much Justice I'm
sad to say there was one thing and one
thing only I thought was interesting
about that premises questions it was the
one at the end and it was the exchange
between the ex-cabinet minister Simon
Clark and Oliver Dowden now viewers
might have seen some of the reporting in
the last few days around questions
around what's going on T side now the
conservative teas Valley mayor there has
come into questions about quite how a
development in the area has been
conducted and there's an interesting
question for how the Downing Street and
how the government machine respond to
this and what's absolutely clear is that
Oliver down I'm sure he's speaking for
Richardson he's going to stand shoulder
to shoulder with Ben Houchin the teas
Valley mayor and they made that
absolutely clear so there's going to be
a fight a political fight about what
happened in t-side and Downing Street
right now think that the politics of
this is all in doubling down and
standing with him in the face of lots of
questions no proven allegations but lots
of questions and lots of calls for
inquiries okay
um so something to watch uh looking at
how Dan did in the round I mean I've
never seen him so animated how do you
think he did
um you got to see why Oliver Dowden was
for the last five prime ministers the
backroom guy supplying the lines you
know there were some quite uh
interesting lines there the one about um
uh conservatives stop uh the boat's
labor rig vote worth pointing out labor
actually walked back from their plan to
uh give EU Nationals the vote in general
elections that's not part of their uh
plan uh at the moment but what I think
is interesting and worth a lot of
scrutiny is when Oliver Dowden throws in
uh facts about the economy so he said
fastest growth rate in the G7
um now we've been fact checking that
during the prime minister's questions
yes if you look at the figure annually
if you look at the 2020 uh one or 2022
figures that is true in comparison to
Canada France Germany Italy Japan and
the us but when you look at the quarter
on quarter growth actually the UK is
doing uh pretty abysmally it's the
second worst Ed Conway our economics
editor calls it total nonsense to boast
about
um the fastest growth rate in the GDP
growth in the G7 if you're actually
talking about uh actually the slowest so
be careful what you wish for it depends
what time period uh Oliver Dowden is
talking about you have to listen really
hard when they make claims about the
economy in the end I think viewers will
know whether they think the British
economy is doing well or badly indeed
Sam thank you so much for talking us
through that